[Musique]
ce mardi 18 octobre c'est au centre
communal d'action sociale de la Rivière
des Pluies à Sainte-Marie que le
président du Département Cyril Melchior
s'est rendu pour signer avec le maire de
la commune Richard mirlot le pacte de
solidarité territoriale 2e génération un
dispositif qui a déjà fait ses preuves
et qui est destinée à accompagner le
développement des communes et participé
au mieux vivre de la population ainsi
c'est une enveloppe de près de 4
millions d'euros qui sera accordé à la
commune de Sainte-Marie pour financer
ses investissements mais aussi l'action
sociale
au département nous avons mis en place
le pack de solidarité territoriale et je
suis à Sainte Marie pour signer avec son
meilleur Richard niallo et bien le volet
2 de ce pack de solidarité territoriale
près de 4 millions d'euros que nous
accordons la commune de Sainte Marie
doit financer ses investissements mais
aussi l'action sociale et dans l'action
il y a l'accompagnement des personnes
porteuses handicap il y a aussi
l'accompagnement des jeunes notamment au
niveau des PMI de conduire et aussi
l'accompagnement titre du Centre
Communal d'Action Sociale j'ai assisté
ici à des travaux avec des enfants des
travaux avec des mamans qui apprennent
la couture et bien ces actions sont
cofinancées par le Département
d'Amérique mais au-delà de ça je
voudrais dire que nous participons aussi
au financement de grands travaux le
centre administratif les travaux
routiers avec la sécurisation des
piétons l'éclairage public les trottoirs
les pistes cyclables sur les routes
départementales et bien tout cela nous
le faisons ici à Sainte-Marie pour aider
à son développement et lui permettre un
meilleur accompagnement de proximité de
la population le CCAS de la commune
bénéficiera de près de 700 000 euros
dans le cadre du PST2
à travers la signature du solidarité
territoriale numéro 2
qui était lancé par le président
2018 est une excellente chose c'est un
bel outil pour accompagner les communes
qui sont déjà en difficulté et je
voulais remercier le président du
conseil départemental justement de nous
accompagner justement d'une manière très
propre pour continuer ce développement
social au niveau des équipements aussi
la mise en place des équipements et il y
a tellement de belles actions menées
ensemble et nous l'avons nous allons le
faire le déplacement du président du
département sur le territoire
sainte-marien a été ponctué par la
visite des travaux d'aménagement de la
rd61 sur le secteur de carocotons ou la
collectivité a notamment réalisé une
passerelle piétonne sur l'ouvrage de la
ravine la mare
la convention prévoit de mettre l'accent
sur l'amélioration très légère de
l'habitat à travers des opérations
destinées à soutenir les familles dans
la réalisation des travaux
trois grands chantiers seront également
financés un nouveau collège privé de 450
élèves une cité administrative ainsi
qu'une nouvelle caserne à Beauséjour
[Musique]